damn he's cute I pulled that yes I want
to wear this guy but I know once I get
my chair up whole poem will be out and
that is not what I'm trying to give ya
where's my wheelchair adaptive skirt cuz
I need to be comfortable oh that is yeah
I gotta give them a little something
since I have to be my chair the whole
time
where's that push-up bra yeah is it oh
it is heels or boots heels or boot heels
or boots heels I'm not walking in these
[ __ ] anyway whoo okay it's 450
perfect the assist driver has enough
time to put the chair together before he
shows up which works because I can show
my independence oh wait let me drop a
pair to my besties safety first did I
eat my mitt before I got out the car I
hold my breath don't sting wait oh my
gosh is that him oh that's it keep it
you girl don't slouch strain your back
put your phone away girl oh he gets
strong hugs he won't have any trouble
caring me up the stairs when there's no
elevator I usually go for shorter guys
so they won't tell me in my chair too
much but I met at this tall drink of
water I'm just glad he's as cute in
person as he isn't his photos you did
that low ooh the chicken breast sounds
good but don't need his help cutting it
should I ask him not too soon I'll just
get some pasta
John Gill I have to lean in when he's
talking I can't sit back in my chair
I'll be too far away connection baby
connection you know I had a really good
time today mm-hmm he's just as fine as
he wants to be the Lord took his time
with him oh I gotta say something yeah
it was it was really great yeah I know
you said you wanted to take the races
today but I don't mind picking you up if
you ever decide to change your mind let
me find out today I need to get home
before rides start to surge maybe I
should let him take me home then nah he
can't have my address this soon he
helped break my chair down and put it in
the car oh he's so freaking cute I can't
wait till he getting this person oh I'm
a hot mess but I'm just saying up got a
hug and a kiss on the cheek super
winning he's definitely into you today
was fun I guess gentlemen do exist and
don't mind being seen with me yes um did
it get it Hey gonna get it up oh yeah
[Music]
ladylike is moving to our own new
channel where you're going to find more
of the great videos you love click here
to subscribe